Okay.
Hey,
what's going on?
It's bill burn.
It's the Monday morning podcast for Monday.
Sorry,
that was obnoxious for Monday.
September 15th,
2014 how's it going?
How are you?
What's up?
I'm fucking house is hot as shit.
Goddamn AC.
I don't know what's going on with it.
I really got to stop doing this.
I've got to stop trashing my house because someday you know,
maybe I'll sell it,
you know,
and no matter how many photos I put up,
that makes it look like it's all shiny and new.
Come aboard.
We want to sell it to you.
It's my shit.
Oh,
they added the bottom floor in the 50s my shit.
are you willing to dry rot wood?
Because that's what I have behind all the plaster.
You see?
Sorry.
Now we're actually turning the fucking corner downstairs.
They've roughed it up and they are ready to now put the final touches
on a downstairs.
That should have been built like this to begin with.
You know what my downstairs basically is because this originally was a one floor
house.
It's like an expansive expansion franchise.
My downstairs when I bought this House on bill notes to me was the Tampa Bay
Buccaneers in 1977.
Okay.
And Sam,
that's Sam huff.
Gary hough.
Gary Gary Hoffa.
I think this is the name of the original Tampa Bay Buccaneers,
quarterback.
Um,
that,
um,
of that team that went,
oh,
and 14.
He designed the downstairs.
All right.
Hey designed the fucker downstairs.
So anyways,
everything has been corrected.
Everything has been aligned,
everything is square.
Everything is true.
Learning all these construction words.
All right.
That and uh,
Hey,
uh,
I don't know if you saw the last invoice,
but we're still waiting for payment.
That's another big construction term.
You know what kills me?
Those motherfuckers,
they somehow they put a flat on when I'm on my,
I,
uh,
my bicycle,
it's not my bicycle,
it's the one I bought for Nia and she never used it,
you know?
So I actually ride it now I write it through the canyons.
No,
every once in a while take it out for a spin and a,
I should have known because the front tie needed a little bit of air.
But the back one was just done and I pumped him back up and everything was good.
I listened,
I didn't hear any sound,
so I thought it was fucking fine.
And then I went down there and you know,
just one of the added costs and I got to tell you if I was a cunt,
not saying I'm not,
but if I was like a a motivated,
if I was trying to make all American in the current category,
I would actually take the whatever's going to cost me to have somebody put a new
fucking inner tube in it.
If it was the front tire,
I do it myself,
but it's the back tire and a,
you know,
old freckles doesn't have time for that shit.
I could go on Youtube share,
I could do it not to change back tire and move all of that shit out of the way
and I could get all fucking greasy and then have to go down to home depot and
buy that fucking that,
that,
that sad.
That cuts through the grace and I'd be down there for nine hours,
you know,
and afterwards,
yeah,
I'd feel like a man,
you know,
or I could just drop it off and have somebody fucking do it.
And um,
I could sit here and eat a pizza.
No,
not at pizza.
Not a piece.
I got to have a salad.
I got to turn this shit around.
Um,
a couple of weeks ago,
I don't know what happened,
like two and a half weeks ago,
I had whatever the meal was that sent me back down the road,
eating bad and been eaten bad for two weeks.
And the other day I walked by the mirror and I knew I'd put on a few and I just,
I just was so fucking disgusted with myself,
you know,
and fuck all you assholes out there that say that fat shaming doesn't work.
You know,
it doesn't work.
It's what it really is,
is know you're fat and you don't want to hear it.
That's what it is.
I,
whenever I say shit about fat people,
it's not a negative way.
All right.
I'm trying to motivate you.
It's how I motivate myself.
I walked by the mirror and I look at myself when I go,
you fucking piece of shit.
Really.
All that fucking work.
We did all those months of work,
all those pull ups,
all those pushups,
all those fucking hikes.
And what did she do?
What did you do?
You get it.
Oh wait,
no,
wait.
That's what kills me about when you're at my age is I can live,
I can negate three months of being at the gym in four meals,
not for meals,
but like in a week and a week of just being an asshole.
Everything that I gained,
I can just fucking lose.
It's the,
it's the absolute worst.
So then if you don't know how to dye it,
what you do is then you start lifting weights and that type of shit and you keep
eating bad and all you're doing is you're putting these pex and biceps on top of
the big belly,
right?
Roll out the barrel.
We'll have a barrel of fun.
Right?
And He'd just become that guy,
that guy who just keeps lifting weights and keeps eating shit food.
And all you're trying to do is keep your man packs just a little bit out in
front of your fucking stomach.
And then what do you do?
You start pushing down the fucking pants.
You Belt Line's fucking digging into your pubes.
So dude,
I'm still a fucking dirty to winch way saint j j side to and high school and
he'd just keep pushing it down and push until the point it looks like somebody
yanked your belt and all the fat when boiling up to yeah,
literally bleeding just like that.
It was a bad sound effect,
but you know what I'm saying?
All the way up into your gut and then it ran into your fucking man pecs that
held it down and it's just fucking sitting there
cry,
caught between a rock and a hard place.
That'd be a pecs and you declare sorry.
Um,
so I'm trying to avoid that.
That's the hardest fucking thing is to lose weight and not lose muscle,
you know,
and fuck all you guys who are going to come in and meet with your GNC chemicals.
All right.
And talking about protein,
the size of your hand.
I've heard all of it.
All right,
but what are you supposed to do when that fucking redneck comes on TV and says,
I got big news.
They've now put bacon in,
in,
in fucking cheese,
in the crust,
whatever the fuck he said actually retweeted the quote.
Why don't I look it up?
This is how fucked up it is,
right?
And this guy's just sitting there,
hey,
I got big news.
I got big news people.
You know,
people who may be are in between jobs and can't afford quality food.
And rather than encouraging me to go out and get an apple or a banana,
you know what I'm going to say?
I'm going to where the fuck is a thick.
Okay?
They'll find my tweet here.
I gotta find my fucking Twitter.
Uh,
Jesus.
What the fuck is,
I apologize.
You know,
I have big news.
Bacon and cheese have been stuffed into a crust.
That's what this guy says is he sits in his fuck.
Do you think that fucking cunt is eaten?
Maybe he's eaten a little bit of it.
He gets from the south.
And I'll tell you he don't know no better.
Okay?
I'll tell you what though.
I think better than that,
greasy Italian food is if you shove a little biking integration across,
there you go.
Did you like that joke?
I attack two fucking people.
Actually.
I really was just making fun of southerners,
right?
I Dunno.
Anyways,
and he's just sitting there collecting the money.
Basically sitting in the guard tower is all of us fucking march into fucking eat
that poison.
How do you do that in good conscious.
How can you sit there as a country singer?
All right.
All about your family values and supporting the troops and denying global
warming.
How can you sit there,
cross your fucking wrangler jeans with just shit kicking boots on and say,
well America,
I have big news.
Bacon and cheese had been stuffed into a crust.
Okay,
you mother fucker.
It was stuffed into a duffle bag,
a bunch of fucking cash for you to go out and buy some scope,
band it right and go get a replica of the fucking dukes of Hazzard car while
everybody else goes in and they add to their fucking man tits.
How dare you,
you're already quit on your fucking music career.
The second you got in that lazy boy where you spin around and face the crowd,
then you come back around and tell somebody from the,
from a warehouse that they got a shot,
whatever,
fucking,
whatever that show is.
You know what's funny is back in the day whenever you did shows like that,
you never made it and now people actually make it,
you know?
Do you remember a long time ago on MTV they had making the band?
Nobody ever made it.
Nobody ever fucking made it.
That's why I never went on last comic standing.
I never went on that cause I,
I,
that's all I thought about was MTV making the band.
Everybody who went on making the band never made it.
I was thinking,
you know,
Nirvana wasn't on making the band.
They didn't do a show like that did,
did you know good Cinderella?
Go on making the bed.
I don't think they did.
You know,
went on the band.
Oh,
went on that fucking the real world.
So they still do that show.
We played seven fucking beat.
Atlanta has made me see what happens.
I love her.
They like a point of pride with MTV.
This is where it all started.
Oh,
you mean that Shit TV.
Will you take regular people and exploit them and have them scream at each
other?
Oh Bill,
get off your fucking high horse.
She watched it just like the rest of us.
All right.
You're right.
I do.
And then I have,
I told you I started watching that fucking arm wrestling show,
Battle of arms or whatever it is.
It's the funniest shit I've ever seen in my,
at least guys are fucking out of their minds.
Get in each other's faces right before the arm wrestle war God screaming at each
other.
Fucking slamming the table around.
I love that show.
These fucking guys would rip your goddamn arm off.
Um,
I don't know what their deal is.
Some of them are actually like,
they can't help being like that.
And then there's other ones that are fucking terrified.
I don't know what it is.
They had a bad father and now they're going to try to become like as close as
they can do a God damn superheroes.
So they,
they,
they got us every pull up.
They got a scream.
Ahhh.
Right?
Shouting the fear out of them.
Whatever.
Good for them.
You know,
God bless them.
In other words,
I don't have anything else to say about that topic.
So whenever I don't,
I just gay.
You know what?
God bless him.
God bless those sons of bitches.
My arms all swollen.
I didn't know that that happened.
And when you arm wrestle to that point,
that one of your arms just blew up like a balloon.
I remember back in the day when you were out in the back Yad and a mosquito got
on you.
If you flex your muscle really quick,
they couldn't release and you'd blow him up with your own blood.
You remember doing that shit lie.
Do I remember?
Because I came up before the Internet.
Why isn't my fucking AC cool enough?
This room?
Can you hear it?
Can you hear it humming in the background?
Oh,
it's trying that acs trying.
Just like I'm trying right now.
I'm trying to entertain you.
Fucks for another God damn hour on another fucking Monday,
right bear.
It is people.
Congratulations.
You lived in other week,
starting all over again.
What are you doing right now?
How you sitting in your fucking car in traffic?
You behind that Douche bag who for some reason leaves two and a half car lengths
between him and the other car on a flat surface on a dry road for whatever
reason he's doing that and yet another person is cut into your lane.
Yeah.
Do Your Lane
and you sit in,
they're gripping the steering wheel.
Go and you know what?
In a perfect fucking world,
perfect.
What can world I would punch through his side window like the terminator.
I would pull him up by his fucking throat.
Lift him high into the air.
Yeah.
Choke the life.
Don't just almost to an inch of his life.
Leave them by the side of the road and then get in his car.
Mine the only one thinks shit like that.
I don't think I am.
I think it's a very normal thought.
Um,
anyway,
so this is the Monday morning podcast and um,
it's football Sunday right now it's actually one 18.
I just watched the New England patriots.
Somehow after that first horrific drive,
they finished off the Minnesota Vikings.
I gotta tell you,
man,
I love seeing the vikings playing outside.
Again,
reminded me a way back in the day was Fran Tarkington,
Jim Masha,
Paul Crouch,
Chuck Foreman over that Alan Page,
Carl Eller.
You know all these guys.
As I'm saying them,
I'm picturing football cards,
stu void or some shit.
Who's that?
Fucking Ron Yari.
Maybe he was in the 80s when they had Tony Kramer,
Tommy,
Tommy Kramer.
Um,
he played indoors.
They,
they,
I,
when I started watching football,
the vikings still still played outside I think for like one or two seasons.
It was the late seventies,
I think it was just the last season or it might've been,
I was just watching those NFL films all the time.
So I think I remembered it.
I have no idea.
Oh fuck the Seahawks and charges a plane.
Hang on.
I got to hit pause.
I gotta I gotta record this game.
Hold on,
hold on,
hold on.
Okay,
I'm back.
Sorry.
I had to make sure I recorded that game.
I want to watch that game.
Uh,
okay.
You know that's one of those games I got to tell you.
You know,
could go either way.
The Seattle Sea hawks have looked very impressive early this year and the
national football league season of 2014
okay.
But you gotta remember these shoes,
your division rivalry even know they're not in the same division.
They've played each other for years.
They know what each other does.
It's really good to come down to who's going to strap it on.
What did they mean by that?
Strap it on.
You got to strap it on,
looked at other guy on the eye.
You got to play some smash mouth football.
That's what they need to do.
You see any Diego charges for years had been trying to get over the hump,
the,
the of,
they've created a culture where they get to the big game,
but they just cannot seem to get to the big dance.
Okay.
Sorry.
Um,
you know what's funny is I make of it and the only way I know everything that
they say is because I watch it all the time and I can't stop fucking watching
it.
I can't stop fucking watch it know.
Um,
anyways,
plowing ahead here.
Uh,
let's get back to the fucking,
what did I want to talk about this week?
Let's just get out of football because I know it was a lot of people that don't
like football.
Not that I give a fuck,
but I,
you know,
I don't wanna I don't want to bore you 100%.
So,
uh,
what,
what are you doing this week?
You know what I'm doing,
uh,
coming up on,
coming up on all,
wait,
scatterbrained.
Scatterbrain hit the brakes.
Um,
I want to let you guys know on Twitter I announced it,
my,
uh,
my long awaited Carnegie Hall recording.
I did a show there on November 11th,
2011 and the album is finally coming out.
I did it on a third man records Jack White label in Nashville,
Tennessee.
And this was the thing,
um,
you know,
I was doing a show at Carnegie Hall and I was getting ready to do a special
video and shooting whatever a special at Carnegie Hall would.
It costs me $9 million.
Why?
Because their Carnegie hall and they know everybody wants to record there.
So they charge it 10 million times.
What the fuck they should be charging.
So it's Carnegie Hall.
I don't know if I'm ever going to be back.
It's like I got to record this.
I got a document that I'm going to be there.
Right?
So I did,
they charged me 10,
15,000 times.
What the fuck they should have charged.
But I didn't give a shit cause it was Carnegie Hall.
Lo and behold,
they will.
Right.
So,
uh,
three months later I recorded,
you people are all the same.
And then about like a year later,
I finally got the tapes.
That's how slow things move.
Um,
I could've got access into the White House quicker.
Then I got the tapes from my,
uh,
my show there.
And,
and it was one of the deals with just the overlap because it was like three,
four months between that recording and my next special that it was basically,
I don't know,
80,
85%,
75% the same shit.
I,
you know,
I tell it differently every night,
but it's the same shit.
So I want to fucking put it out there that I've been there.
I don't want to fuck people over by,
you know,
acting actually acting like this isn't,
this is new material.
It isn't,
it's just this performance of that material.
So,
uh,
I decided that I was putting it out on vinyl,
lonely and a that way it's,
you know,
even though it's the same thing,
it's like a different sort of,
I don't know.
I think albums are cool and I know everybody for some reason to quite some to
hipsters,
which I guess is fair.
But to be honest with you guys,
I'm 46 years old.
I grew up when,
you know,
I remember when cassette tapes came out,
um,
you know,
all of my shit when I first got it was on vinyl.
I don't think it sounds better.
I can't tell if it sounds better.
I have no fucking idea.
What I do like is I like,
I liked albums at first.
I liked the cassettes where it was all small and that type of Shit,
oh this is great.
I can take it in the car and all that type of thing.
Then after a while and went back to the vinyl and now this as much fucking cool.
You get all these extra pictures,
you know,
who's a fucking event.
I liked it,
so whatever.
So some people giving me shit for doing it.
I don't give a fuck.
The fact that it's on vinyl,
I just look at it as if you actually buy this fucking thing,
he can't give me shit.
It's that is the,
the pretty much the same thing.
It's just I've told you from day one.
Okay,
so I don't want to fucking hear it even though I'm still going to hear it.
And all you guys with your dumb jokes.
Well you put your next special out on Betamax,
snort,
laughing my ass off.
I don't give a fuck.
Um,
it's really cool.
And uh,
so let me tell you a little bit about the album.
If you look at the cover of the album,
you'll see old Billy red face standing on stage,
grinning ear to ear,
but there's not a soul in the place.
Um,
because we could not shoot during the show.
Those were the rules.
Union house,
Carnegie Hall,
Go Fuck Yourself with Carnegie Hall.
So I had to take the photo then.
All right.
And uh,
my photographer was allowed to be,
I dunno,
there was a little hole in the wall.
He was able to stick the camera through and take pictures.
It was fucking insane.
It was insane.
And the navel,
the name of the album is called live at Andrew's house.
And,
um,
and then that was just another thing where I wanted to say live at Carnegie
Hall,
but that was going to be like,
you know,
I was just going to be another thing,
but we have to get that approved,
you know?
Oh,
you've got to approve that.
I was,
I mean I was there.
I paid the money to rent out the thing.
You know,
you saw the show.
He didn't have prompt while we still have to send it up,
send it up the flag pole,
but blah,
blah blah blah.
And I just said fuck it.
Fuck it.
I won't,
I don't need to say that.
I'll just say live at Andrew's house.
There you go.
Andrew Carnegie.
Alright.
There you go.
So there you go.
There's a little history there.
Okay.
Alrighty.
Okay,
so that's going to be available I think on September 30th.
Um,
the preordering is like,
ah,
Jesus.
Bill,
why don't you go,
why don't you just get the fucking information before you start talking about
it?
You dumb.
Fuck.
Um,
let me see here.
Let me see here.
Where is it?
My gravy that dawn Doma gravy.
No,
these aren't them.
German cars are the best German cars go to the next level.
By the way,
I'm back into that Mercedes Benz,
uh,
that Mercedes Benz fucking station wagon.
I just think that's the coolest thing.
All right.
Um,
is this it here?
Okay.
Presale is on September 16th,
which is tomorrow.
If you're listening to it,
uh,
on Monday,
you know,
if you listened to them the right time,
if you're not,
it's probably already out.
That's the presale is nine 16 and it's on sale.
Nine 30 full details,
full detail.
Excuse me.
Hiccups are@thirdmanrecords.com.
Um,
I hope you guys like it.
I've already given a couple of copies of people and they'd say it's awesome,
but they're also friends of mine,
so I imagine you costs will be a little more honest dude.
It fucking sucked.
Um,
all right,
back to the,
uh,
to the podcast.
So this week after the ray rice scandal,
now you got Adrian Peterson and um,
I got to admit,
I was absolutely shocked by that fucking story.
Yeah.
Um,
I know that,
you know,
that's something that has gone on for a long fucking time.
Parents beating that children like that.
I just,
for some reason I just didn't think,
you know,
with all this doctor Phil Shit,
all his pop psychology shit that's out there,
how you could hit a kid with a switch that's four years old to the point that
he's a bruised and bleeding is just fucking beyond
my comprehension.
That's just fucking nuts.
I think that that really fucks obviously really fucks people up when you,
when you,
when you do shit like that.
Um,
to that level.
Not Saying I didn't get hit as a kid,
but two things.
One,
it wasn't a switch.
It was a paddle and two,
I fucking deserve it.
I never felt after getting hit with the paddle that I never felt
okay.
Um,
that it was wrong.
Now what is it?
What am I,
what's the word I'm searching for?
I never felt that I didn't,
uh,
didn't do something to deserve it.
I hated it because it hurt,
but I never felt that it was a,
yeah.
Like it was,
um,
I dunno,
like all I did was this and then you did that.
The only time I ever felt it was fucking wrong was one time my brother said that
I kicked my other brother in the face and it was bullshit.
I kicked him in the stomach.
I used to do a bit about that.
And it was that which was considered working it out amongst yourselves.
And uh,
you know,
the face was in,
no,
in my house was where'd you could punch in the side of the head if you bruised
within the hair,
you know,
the parents wouldn't see it then you'd be all right.
But if he hit in the face then you know,
then you had a big problem and um,
okay.
Yeah.
My mother was brushing her hair at the time.
She turned around,
she went to whack me over the head with a brush and I ducked and she caught me
right between the shoulder blades and the brush was like this hard plastic and
it kind of exploded.
And,
um,
then my mother picked up the brush part,
the rubber part with the thing sticking out.
And for I think another 10 years I,
she brushed her hair just holding onto that
rather than the whole with the handle and all that.
Like that's how,
um,
I dunno my parents,
their parents grew up in the depression so they just had that instilled in them
that you,
you know,
if the brush breaks into a million pieces,
you still salvage it.
It still works.
You just hold it this way,
you know which rig,
you know,
maybe that's a smarter thing to do.
I have no idea.
But anyways,
taking it to that level.
So I actually was reading about that and then that reminded me of the story.
Now this comes with a warning because you probably shouldn't watch this video,
but it reminded me of which I thought was like seven,
eight years ago.
Turns out it was 20 years ago.
Remember that kid was like Michael Fay or something like that.
Was that,
uh,
okay.
It was a 19 year old kid.
He was over in Singapore and he was accused of vandalizing some property or some
shit and the punishment,
what part of the punishment was he was going to get caned and you know,
nobody over here and heard of it for the most part unless you'd traveled and it
was basically they hit you with this fucking stick and um,
okay.
You know,
they hit hits you hard enough that after a couple of hits,
like basically like they said pieces of flesh or coming off you fucking ass in
the back of your legs and stuff and everybody thought it was fucking horrific.
He was supposed to get six hits and we were allowed to while we made enough of a
stink that they went down to four hits.
And so I looked that up and then there was a link to a video that showed
somebody getting caned and I got to tell you,
don't watch it.
Don't watch it.
I watched it.
It's like a four and a half minute video dude.
And I'm telling you because what happened with Michael Fay kid is like the day
after or something,
he was sitting down it.
He's like,
oh that wasn't that bad.
That kid is a tough kid.
He's not like a 40 year old man.
But I gotta tell you something.
I watched this video,
dude,
it's you go out there right naked as a Jay bird,
whatever the fuck that means.
And then they put you in this thing that's almost like a,
it's like what they,
I dunno,
it's,
you're basically,
I don't know,
like if you had like a two wheel Dolly,
you remember how they wield Hannibal Lecter out marriages.
They wheeled him out except he was facing the other way.
All right,
but there's no wheels on this thing and you walk and you stand on that thing.
Then you hang onto these two fucking handles and two people on either side hold
on to your arms and then they put this thing over you with is basically,
I guess it's to protect your lower back and the back of your legs,
you know,
so they don't hit that part and then just your ass is poking through the fucking
hole.
It's like a glory hole except it's your ass.
Um,
and then this fucking dude,
Singaporean dude,
Filipino dude,
whatever you call them,
he lines up ready to hit you.
Any weights for some fucking guy off camera to be like,
right.
And this fucking guy is just like in that classic Asian,
like martial arts.
I can't even describe it.
Crouching Tiger Hidden Dragon like I am.
I'm going to fucking,
I'm going to show the West what fucking torque is really capable of.
I can't even do it.
It looked like he was getting ready to do some dance.
He was,
fuck.
I'm literally trying,
I'm acting it out,
right.
I'm standing up right.
Basically you stand up,
he's turned sideways,
like he's gonna hit a fucking golf ball.
Then he fucking,
Ben's his back leg.
So his right leg,
his front leg is straight and his fucking arm is all the way up like this guy
and he's ready to just fuck.
And he just,
and the guy goes and this guy just goes fucking wop and the dude right by the
second one and then they fucking wait like 30 seconds is just sitting there and
this fucking guy is standing there.
He's supposed to hold the,
the fucking Alma said switched the,
came a different way and he's standing there and then some guy mumbles some
shit,
right?
And then the fucking guy goes back into that,
that,
that priest stance.
It looks like a fucking marvel comic like action hero.
Right.
And then the guy goes and look,
fucking the guy goes,
wow,
hits him again.
The guy goes look like by the second one
you sound like a puppy getting kicked.
All right.
And I swear to God the camera,
cause I think they were trying to show how abusive it is.
Then zoomed in on this dude's ass and he's got like fucking two lines now.
I think by the second hit it was getting raw and both of his butt cheeks were
like fucking quivering,
like anticipation and through this was like a four and a half fucking,
I lost count.
I think they hit him like five fucking times.
But uh,
literally by the fourth time the guy started to like crumpled.
Dude.
It was fucking brutal.
I don't even know why I'm telling,
I'm just saying this is like classic Internet thing.
Like I went on NFL,
nfl.com and then next thing you know I'm watching somebody get caned in
Singapore.
Then that's what's great about the Internet is it just,
it breaks down boundaries.
It brings people closer.
I don't know what to tell you.
I don't even what the point of all of that was.
Um,
I told you what happened.
You can watch it if you want to watch it.
I'm not putting the link up because I never,
I never watched shit like that and I don't know why I did.
It's just like one of those things,
cause it didn't seem like it was going to be that bad and you start going
through,
could I take that?
Could I sit there and for and for the,
for America not cry out.
You know,
you just got to get the first one in to understand the level.
I would think that that would be,
Nah,
after you got the first one,
then then,
then that's psychologically be like,
fuck,
I got like three this fucker.
I could tell you what the u s government did for that Michael Fay dude that
they,
they got rid of the last two.
Okay.
I mean Jesus fucking Christ like,
and the way I've described it now,
there's no way you're not going to watch it,
but I'm not putting the fucking linkup but Jesus,
there's no how many you think you could take?
Do you know the other kid that will got arrested with them?
I'm Louie talking about a fucking new story from 20 years ago.
The other kid was lined up for 12 of those hits and they knocked his down to 10
dude,
you fucking unconscious by eight.
Okay.
There's just no way.
You either unconscious or you can't even feel your ass anymore.
Your ass
fucking voice cracking.
Um,
yeah,
do it.
There's,
that's a,
that's surprising that that is a,
I don't know,
is it really surprising the only shit that's going on?
That's why I don't watch the fucking news.
I don't,
I have no idea.
Anything that's really going on,
I have to get better.
Especially now that I'm building an hour.
Um,
I got to sat watching it,
but like I've never been one of those people that could watch like execution
videos and fucking all like people who sit down and they watch those guys
getting beheaded over there.
I mean,
that's,
that does something to you to sit down and watch that.
Um,
I dunno.
You know,
it's funny right now is the re,
you know,
reason why I wish I didn't watch that video.
I'm gonna tell you what's going to happen if you watch that fucking video.
That dude's quivering ass is going to be burned into your fucking brain for like
three days because now that's just what I'm thinking right now.
I'm trying to go on to the next subject.
Do you understand this?
And there's a man's quivering ass.
It's in my,
no disrespect to that guy.
This guy took it like a fucking champ.
Okay.
Jesus fucking Christ.
You know what the,
if you saw the way this guy was swinging this cane,
like they go to school for it,
maximum fucking
velocity,
Torque,
whatever the fuck you going to call it.
All of that shit.
Okay.
It's like they must have measured it out.
Jesus quite,
you know,
you always hear about Singapore to how fucking clean.
I'm actually afraid to go over there cause that's one of those things like if
you spit gum out on the street,
you know that's considered,
that's a crime and next thing you know you're fucking bare ass sitting there
with a quiver and ash,
just some guys going,
hey,
fuck that.
Fuck that.
Not saying that bad people.
I'm just saying I can't live up to those standards.
I'm going to do something.
Stub my toe and then Kirsten public height.
Yeah,
I would,
I,
that's what I would do.
I'd be fucking screaming like a bitch.
My pasty quivering ass.
Isn't that what you wanted to think on a Monday morning?
Sorry.
How's your Danish?
Um,
anyways,
um,
okay.
Jesus Christ.
I bet that that guy has fucking,
that guy will get Kate or anybody who gets caned.
Anytime somebody old bends over to tie their shoes and they get a pain in their
back and they go,
they like their asked starts just fucking tenses up.
Like they're going to get fucking hit.
Um,
we got a pill.
We got it.
They hit people with wood in Singapore.
There you go.
You learn something.
Um,
all right,
let's get on.
Let's get onto something else here.
Um,
as always,
people,
if you want to donate to the podcast,
the best way to do it is to not have to give me any money.
Well,
God,
how do I do that?
Simple.
Next time you're going to buy something on amazon.com,
just go to [inaudible] dot com first click on the podcast page and then click on
the Amazon.
Lincoln.
We'll take you right to Amazon.
Doesn't cost you any extra money,
but if you come from my website,
they kicked me a few bucks.
There you go.
You kick me a few bucks and then I throw it into the basement.
Sorry.
Um,
anyways,
continuing on.
Um,
I don't know if I mentioned this to you.
you know,
when we aren't at the house,
I can't bring my awesome dog with me everywhere I go.
So,
uh,
but I also didn't want a sticker in a little fucking Kennel thing.
Uh,
but she gets freaked out if she's in the house by herself because somebody left
or by a river.
So she does not like to be alone.
But,
uh,
the dog trainers say,
but if you put them in like a small sort of container,
they don't feel overwhelmed by the space.
They just curl up and go to sleep.
Well that's not my dog.
My dog then tries to fucking break out of it and it does.
And then it's upstairs and it's sitting there wagging its tail and you know,
it chipped a tooth or it's got a cut on his face and it fucking kills me.
So what I did was I had this guy,
I met this guy and he made these giant,
what looked like a fucking lion's cage and it was all this fucking rebar,
so it was this bigger place where she could ever bed and a place for a food,
you know,
it's like a studio apartment as opposed to a little case.
So I fucking put it used to put her in that and it was all good.
She tried to get out of it a little bit.
Then she realized that I,
that I couldn't,
at least I thought that that was the case and um,
she fucking broke up.
She fucking,
she found the weakest bar because it wasn't attached on both sides.
It was only attached
just the way it was attached.
I don't know how it figured it out,
but it just used all of its body weight and it made both welds fail and then it
took that bar and buried it under his bed and then squeezed itself at some
point.
I still a bit on this thing too.
Another one.
At some point it did a pull up or a dad to do a pull up and then a dip and got
out the top of the fucking cage.
So it then took this cage that I spent 700 bucks on and just rendered the whole
fucking thing useless.
It's an I just take her everywhere I go and cause eventually I was going to have
that thing welded back on and uh,
I don't know what happened.
I just started looking up for welders.
I stuck looking at welding.
I got into this shit.
I think it's a school.
Oh cool.
A skill to learn.
So I'm going to take a six hour do it yourself fucking welding thing and I'm
going to fucking,
well that thing back on myself.
I'm going to give it a shot and I know what all you guys are thinking,
dude,
you're going to burn your fucking house down.
There's no fucking way is dumb as I am.
Okay.
Give me a little credit.
There's no fucking way I would weld anything near my house.
Okay.
I'll pay the guys down at the shop to let me do it at their shop under their
supervision.
Okay.
Before you call me a moron and before you predict all this fucking disaster,
I'm not saying I'm not going to burn something down.
It just won't be mine.
All right.
That's the deal.
I think learn and Hardo I'm learning until,
well,
I think learning how to weld is a really fucking coolest skill.
It really is an a,
I'll show you a link to a the best video of it that I've found.
Unless I get rid of it,
please tell me I didn't get rid of it.
This guy was awesome.
He was totally clear.
He had a fucking mustache.
Oh,
Jesus Christ.
You motherfucker.
Bill,
you're the worst.
You just the fucking worst.
I will find it.
I will find it and I'll,
I'll,
I'll give you the fucking link and if I don't,
just remind me.
How's that?
Does that work for you?
Well,
I don't give a shit.
Oh my God.
37 minutes and I haven't even,
Holy Shit,
we haven't done any advertising it.
Um,
all right,
let's let's get on with it here.
All right.
Draft kings,
everybody.
Dude,
I called it.
I said these guys were going to be huge.
I said they were going to be huge and they are huge.
A draft kings fantasy football's back and draft kings.com isn't messing around.
Draft kings.com is America's favorite one week fantasy football site where you
could win enormous cash prizes every week.
You've already researched to players for your season long fantasy team.
Turn that knowledge into instant cash.
where@draftkings.com last year,
one player turned 11 bucks and the four grand and only one weekend,
another one a hundred grand.
His first time ever playing,
oh Jesus and another player won a million bucks in one day.
Just playing fantasy football or you see what's going on here.
People are making money off of the information you already have.
Keep your season long league where it is,
but also play one week fantasy@draftkings.com to when huge amounts of cash this
weekend.
Hurry,
get free entry into the millionaire maker event where first place takes home 1
million bucks.
Head over to draft kings.com now and enter the Promo Code Promo Code Defense,
D F,
e n s e to play free to become a millionaire,
draftkings.com bigger events,
bigger winnings,
bigger millionaires.
Enter defense for free entry now@draftkingsdotcomdraftkings.com that's draft
kings.com hit you over the head with that website.
All right,
legal zoom,
everybody.
When you're planning for your future and you do financial planning,
um,
wait.
When you're planning for your future,
you do financial planning,
you get insurance.
But to get real peace of mind,
you got to make sure your family and finances are legally protected.
So where do you turn for legal help?
You can trust simple legal zoom.com for over 13 years they've been helping
Americans get personalized wills,
powers of attorney,
and living trusts.
Legal Zoom also helps file LLCs,
s corporations,
and more to protect you against personal liability.
The company was started by some of the best legal minds in the country and they
make it painless for you to get the legal protection that you need.
If you have questions,
you can always reach out to someone at legal zone and they will talk you through
the process.
You can get legal help through an independent attorney and self help services at
your direction,
but they are not a law firm.
For special savings,
be sure to enter my Promo Code Code Burb,
B U R R and the referral box at checkout.
Go to legalzoom.com Promo Code burr today to protect your business and take
control of your family's future.
Alright,
stamps.com everybody the classic stamps.com everyone computers are designed to
make running a business easier,
including your mailing and shipping.
Just use stamps.com to get 24 hour access to the post office right from your
computer.
No waiting in line,
no hassles,
man stamps.com makes mailing and shipping easy.
Just use the computer and printer you already have to get official US postage
for any letter and package.
Print the posters directly onto envelopes,
labels,
even plain paper,
then hand it to your mail carrier.
That's it.
No guesswork.
stamps.com we'll send you a digital scale that automatically calculates the
exact did you need for any class of mail.
You will never have to go to the post office again.
You know what I use stamps.com to send out all the crap that I sell at the end
of my shows and I'm a moron and I can figure out that scale so there's no excuse
right now.
Use My last name bur bur for this special offer,
no risk trial plus $110 bonus offer that includes a digital scale and up to $55
free postage kid.
Don't wait.
Go to stamps,
job car.
Before you do anything else,
click on the microphone@thetopofthehomepageandtypeinburburthatstamps.com enter
birth.
Jesus,
I'm on such a fucking role here.
Um,
I almost don't want to stop reading these fuckers,
but we're going to get back to the podcast.
Here is,
it's uh,
there's a time for questions.
I don't know here.
Um,
yeah,
I think it's time for questions.
You know what j law head is actually here.
He's over my house right now.
I think he's watching Seattle fucking challenges.
We're going to bring him in here to the podcast.
After these not a message I just gave you messages.
I'm gonna bring him in here through the wonderful world of hitting pause.
All right,
we're back into the wonderful world,
the magic of hitting the pause button.
Uh,
we're now here with the Rosebowl tailgate legend and a gourmet chef of the
outdoor backyard festivities of the Rose Bowl.
The granddaddy of them all.
Jason Law had everybody
from the La Heads Court.
Um,
how's it,
how's it looking in there?
It's good man.
Uh,
San Diego's,
uh,
they got their numbers.
Seattle actually got a touchdown on literally the worst call in the history of
the NFL because these chairs are really squeaky,
by the way.
Sorry.
But what,
what was the call?
You know,
they review every touchdown.
If you score a touchdown,
I review it now.
They have a new system in New York City where they watch every single bit of
film.
Percy Harvin set out on like the 36.
They didn't even reviewed it.
They didn't repeat as court.
He put it on a board and then they go to Mike Perri afterwards.
They're like,
oh yeah,
he stepped out of bounds.
They should uh know the automatic review.
Yeah.
Got Fuck San Diego due.
Can I ask you a question?
What did San Diego do?
You know?
Right.
Cause I know,
I know Cleveland,
you know,
you guys go,
obviously you've been through a bunch of shit,
but there's something like San Diego is always right there,
seven pro bowlers every year and then somehow like there's always either a call
or they shoot themselves in the form of one year.
They had us beat,
they had US speed in a playoff game.
They stopped us on fourth down to get the ball to end of the game.
They took an unnecessary roughness,
call Davis a first down and then we were able to kick a field goal to some
bullshit and I was just like,
well why would you do that?
Then there was like the three or four years ago when they hit that fumble Denver
when they reviewed it and they were like,
yeah,
it was a fumble.
San Diego recovered,
but we're giving it to Denver.
I used to do a whole bit out of when I was living in San Diego by Norv Turner
had a press conference.
How I would've reacted.
I mean they literally the ref went,
yeah,
San Diego recovered it but there was a whistle blown.
So we're giving it back to Denver.
Two plays later.
Denver scores kept San Diego out of the playoffs.
No it's,
it's,
it's a special,
I don't know,
they did something down there that,
that they're getting that level of Karma.
I don't know.
We went to that game a long time ago.
Did not have a good time,
did not,
did not talk game against the titans.
And uh,
I,
we've talked about this I think on the last podcast with the Jersey coming off
in the fight,
that and jersey,
but we got to have a,
the weather's starting to turn into that.
We got to have a pre season tailgate,
you know,
to get us ready for the road
ball.
I mean we gotta have something you want to go to USC game by the way.
Oh good.
Cause I haven't been as a practice.
That's a good practice.
We'll go to USC game,
but can you tailgate down there?
Yeah,
you can actually,
there's a,
it's not as convenient.
I'll go to UCLA.
Higher ranked.
Really do see beat you at USC.
USC is going to be out of the top 25 UCLA is 12th in the country so we should go
to UCLA game.
I know,
but I,
yeah,
I mean the Superbowl one and two were played.
It's fucking Goddamn half hour ride down the street and it's just like I,
I only went there one time.
I saw them play a USC play.
Uh,
Washington huskies in like 96 is the last time I've been there.
I went in La oh seven.
We went there,
we had a two year contract with them and they just waxed us.
That's a year they won a national title.
How State?
We went there with beanie wells,
but he didn't play first game of the season.
Any wells didn't play the first game of the season.
And we got worked over it and it was the only loss we had all year.
We went 12 and won that year.
It was a for a second game of the season at USC as the only time I've ever been
to the coliseum.
Alright,
well I gotta I got again,
tailgaters good tailgate's going on down at the coliseum.
They got a lot of room down there by campus.
It's fun.
Get spoiled yet you UCLA
through luck there.
I won't.
How did I,
I tell Andrew luck to you his senior year to,
how did I not remember that?
I wouldn't even took a little video.
I went down and did a little,
uh,
Nice luck,
luck video.
Like what do you,
what's the luckiest thing that ever happened to you?
I got to show you that the go to law,
head to court,
two page and you can find that.
All right.
Well,
fresh off the,
uh,
the,
the highly successful all in tour,
the first leg of it,
we're hoping to put together a second leg of it.
Uh,
we got the questions for this week.
Um,
let's see what we got here.
It says,
what's new Billy bonanza.
I live in Toronto and was able to see black and white.
It got me thinking,
why don't you have a TV show?
Surely the Hollywood system seems the sees the value in your song and dance.
Get off your lazy ass and come into my living room for 10 weeks out of the year.
Love you and love Nia.
I mean,
how do you answer that?
He would have been smart if he would've,
if he would've wrote lazy ass.
Like you say,
lazy ass or ladies that say that would have been a little bit of flavor he could
have,
but there's no r in there.
Yeah,
that's true.
But ladies don't have an arm.
That's Jerry Lewis.
That's what I'm doing.
I know you are letting you know.
You throw out different references of the,
you stretch the words on different ones.
Well,
maybe he wrote it that way.
It was my read.
All I know is what look you saw the movie black and white.
You know what I love?
I love that I'm in a fucking movie and that's not enough for you.
That wasn't enough for you.
I can have a fucking TV show too.
And then you,
what you do is you'll bitch that my comedy isn't as good because I'd be spending
all my fucking time doing that shit,
pretending to be a fucking police officer.
Whatever the hell thing I would have.
I listen,
I gotta tell you something.
Uh,
I do have some Shit and works,
but uh,
you know,
sometimes a lot of,
it's a blessing to not have a TV show.
It's a blessing to,
in this business,
go on other people's shows because they deal with all the responsibilities,
the writing,
the conference calls,
all of that shit is a go.
When I have time to learn how to weld.
Ask yourself this.
When I have time to learn how to weld,
if I had my own teach TV show,
I could tell you right now the answer is no.
And a lot of you cons out there,
it'd be like,
yeah,
but you had to fucking money to tell somebody else to do it.
Well,
you know what,
I don't live my life that way.
I don't.
I'd like to learn how to do it.
It would reread it like Three Act Academy award winners in this movie.
Yeah.
What am I going back to?
Why we should go do TV?
Movies are great.
You do it.
It's,
it's we have you from this date to this date and then it's done right.
Those other people like who those people on one hour dramas are shooting a movie
that never ends.
Right and I get that.
It's a constant.
You're a constant critic.
Like you get the one time critic.
If it's a good movie,
it's a bad movie.
It's been different.
Whatever that criticism comes in that one stretch.
The TV show is constant criticism.
Old photography,
how hard they,
I don't want to work that hard.
Yeah.
I did an episode of new girl,
I hate a great fucking time.
I think it was 40
18 hour days and they had been,
I did it in February.
It's a half hour show.
They were doing 14 hour days and they had been going since August.
It's just like I thought I work
tart and then I did an episode of that show.
It's like,
dude,
I am a bomb.
And I love it.
That was breaking bad coming back for sure.
They say right.
A better call.
Saul is coming back.
Okay.
Yeah,
it's coming back.
Go to any word on it.
You're doing any Nanos Huh?
Uh,
I have no idea.
I mean if,
if I did,
I couldn't say that I was,
but I,
but to be honest with you,
I haven't heard anything.
No,
Okay.
Silver.
Um,
alright.
Uh,
Silverman props.
Good Day sir.
Ah,
good day.
Good sir.
Sorry,
I saw your name and the end credits.
Uh,
slash thank you.
Have Sarah Silverman's latest comedy,
special,
and was curious if you had anything special to do with the show.
Love your comedy and hope it never ends.
Van.
Very good.
This guy from Germany,
Lars,
you have any,
uh,
I noticed your name and the others are credits.
You know,
it was German guys.
They death.
Everybody they read all the way through,
you know,
they read all the words because just in case there's any like that's why they
can make a station wagon that goes zero to 60 in fucking three and a half
seconds.
Any hidden messages in there they're looking for?
Um,
yeah,
the uh,
that opening bit that she did was she threw the ball against the wall.
Um,
I was down the comedy store like a week before she did,
uh,
her standup special and she was throwing a tennis ball against the wall or
whatever.
And so he's talked to her special.
I was like,
you know,
that could be cool if you're just sitting there throwing the ball against the
wall,
blah,
blah.
Maybe that's why she did it.
Maybe she just thinks I'm a swell guy.
I have no idea.
I should have waited till she told that copy for the search engine optimization.
That's probably,
what is that?
No,
you're like,
we know you tag like things like Bill Burr,
anything popular.
If you'd like to put anything on.
We're like bill burr,
Comma,
um,
you know,
the all end tours.
So when people are searching things like bill burr,
her thing,
ah,
just,
it was kids with the fucking Internet Seo,
they call it search engine optimization.
All right.
Morbid obesity.
Uh,
dear Badass.
Billy Burke,
I guess I'm supposed to give you a nickname.
Yeah,
we're running out here.
People.
You guys don't have to do that,
right?
My brother has been dating a morbidly obese girl for two years now.
My parents are disgusted by this.
Oh,
Jesus.
This is brutal.
It's brutal.
Already.
My mother actually cried when she first met her.
Geez.
Is Christ dude.
And I get shit for fat shaming.
Fuck,
I
thought I raised you better.
Oh yes.
Oh Shit.
Dude.
That's fucking brutal.
More importantly,
her health is clearly in great danger at her weight.
Uh,
it's likely she doesn't get to 40.
My brother's 120 pounds.
She's at least twice as weight.
I'd even say near 300 pounds.
What's a good way to convey the fact that if no one steps in with the harsh
reality,
she's going to have a short life?
Also,
she routinely stumbles out of a cheesecake factory.
Um,
oh,
Jesus Christ.
Dude that's fucking brutal law.
First of all,
I feel bad for her.
I hope she loses the weight cause I get shift on this podcast j because I make
fun of fat people the way I make fun of a lot of shit everything.
And everybody thinks that like out,
you know they don't think that but they say that I've been joking saying fat
shaming works because I do it to myself and all of that type
look at me.
Right.
I fat shaming myself at the beginning of the year cause I saw a picture of us at
the Rose Bowl and I was like,
Hey,
we just go look at my fucking,
I don't know why.
I just don't get how more people don't shame themselves in the foot like shaming
themselves and to getting,
well dude,
you ain't at one point you at one point where pushing 200 pounds and you went to
the doctor and the guy said that 30 pounds overweight.
Yeah.
He was like,
technically I could write you in the or obese.
That's a lot of living in San Diego and I was just like,
still had a real job and was doing comedy coming up and you know,
I had health insurance.
So he was like,
listen,
I with the job and he's like,
I could technically tech with your height,
with your weight,
you could be obese,
but I'm not going to write that in because it could affect your insurance,
you know?
Yeah.
Right.
So he goes,
just get out,
what do you do?
And I told I was,
that's when I was drinking a lot of soda.
I mean,
tons of it.
And that's what if there's people out there,
I'm telling you,
drop that if you don't want,
you know why?
She's wattle one out of a cheese factory because she had three freaking sodas on
top of whatever else she had.
I bet.
And the diets are worse.
He said,
my doctor looked at me and said,
the word diet is the biggest travesty that the food and drug administration
allows because it doesn't mean anything.
Anything's a diet.
If you eat a cow,
that's your diet.
I mean a diet coke just doesn't mean that it's any better for you.
It ain't you.
It ain't going to make you lose weight.
You gain weight.
So that's the one thing that you cut out soda or pop is you guys call it pop.
I got off pop,
I was drinking like he was like,
Geez,
how many of you drink?
And I was like,
I was under a diet.
Dr Pepper is man.
I was knocking back like three,
four day.
And then when I would go golfing I would knock down,
you know,
six of per nine.
I'd have like,
you know,
Plastic Cup.
I go through six,
seven,
eight 10 diet,
diet,
Dr Peppers on it.
Jesus Christ.
Yeah.
He's just,
because I thought I was refreshing myself,
you know,
and it's diet and it tastes good.
I love that doctorate.
I was like,
okay,
it's diet.
And then when I quit that March,
March 1st,
2010 I've only had like Ginger Rail and club soda.
I've never had the like the high fructose and the colon was and I needed that
sugary shit.
It's been and you took it all off and then not so what,
so what,
I just put a bunch on,
uh,
like I'll do one of fall cause just enjoying it,
you know what I mean?
Like we were,
you know,
we had a cook and a lot of holidays.
I hit that holiday party,
that rose bowl.
I mean my birthday is on October 30th.
Right,
right.
So once my birthday hits,
this will be the first time this Halloween candy,
the next day,
the Halloween candy and it goes,
it doesn't stop.
It goes right into thanksgiving.
And before I know it,
I'm a week after New Year's and I'm 30 pounds heavier than I was.
And the love that you acknowledge Hollywood candy,
like you're still trick or treating,
I mean my whole,
my whole childhood,
I was born the day before Halloween is just the weekend apart.
And then when I turned old enough to drink,
this will be because I quit the drinking this year for an experiment.
This will be,
I'm going to turn 42 in October 30th.
Right.
This will be the first time.
I have not had alcohol on my birthday since I was 19 and I'm not going to do it.
I'm not going to do it this year.
I'm going to just,
I'm going to live,
I'm going to walk.
I'm going to walk through the day on my birthday and go,
wow.
Basically 23 years of straight partying because it's always been a party.
It's been like two loves birthday.
Oh wait.
We can mix them together.
I,
there's been,
I don't even know is amazed though number.
Most of my birthdays in the toys by friends,
we were just,
it was a Halloween week.
I was dressed up just walking,
just plowed up.
Jesus Christ.
I mean,
well do you know what amazed me was you,
you,
you were on the wagon from Rosebowl right up until we did the,
the Vegas made though.
Yeah,
but you were so you were like,
I'm drinking this weekend and I'm going right back to being on the wagon,
which is what I said.
And you are able to do it.
I haven't,
I haven't been able to do it.
You had a nice slug,
but you had that part of the year for you was like you just finished a special,
you know,
you,
you knew you were coming with black and white was coming out.
You had a lot of,
did.
There was a lot of reasons for you,
just not the,
you've been good for.
I mean since you started that quit one year,
a couple years ago,
you've been,
you've been able to go and get nice little stretches in,
I haven't been having a very sad but very Sooni key player can tell you.
So the longest I've gone without drinking and this last run was,
I think I had just had a real bad flu for like eight or
nine days that I didn't drink.
And then this has been the longest in my life.
I mean this has been since since I was a teenager.
You've drank like basically three days.
This whole year.
40 minutes,
right?
Yeah,
three days.
Three days.
This whole year.
Oh,
awesome man.
Yeah.
That's awesome.
I wish I then,
I'm not going to have another drink I think until the Rose Bowl.
I think that's just fucking Miller high life.
So I just have like one a day.
Yeah,
but that's not,
you know,
but you know what it is.
It's right after you have it.
Right.
Right after you have that first one.
Yeah.
But the thing is if you just wait five minutes,
if you just drink a water,
if you force yourself to just grab a water or whatever,
your body likes,
stops craving it and you level out and you actually just had that one and you're
able to do it.
But the,
the,
the thing is with food and all of that shit,
for the longest time I was like,
it's not a drug.
It's not drug.
It is,
it is.
It's like whatever you just ate,
you want fucking,
if it's bad for you,
that's how you know it's bad for you because you just ate it.
Now you want more,
which doesn't make any sense because we eat is salad.
You never think like,
Oh dude,
I want salad.
You
don't.
But later on,
if you're hungry,
you're thinking fruit salad,
vegetables.
But you,
you're not thinking like shit food.
But like if you eat,
I've just found if I,
if I did an apple or whatever,
I don't crave another apple.
If I eat a handful of chips,
cookies,
alcohol,
soda or any of that Shit,
that's bad.
Salt or sugar,
you just like you fuck.
It's like you're feening for it.
Sugar.
I mean that's why people are fat.
They can't get off the sugar.
And when you can get off the sugar and you can take it out and you,
the only sugar you get is the natural is like the fruits and vegetable sugars,
the natural sugars.
Your body isn't looking at food like,
oh my God,
I want that.
Your body tells you when it wants food.
So then what?
What does he tell this?
This tells her to get off the sugar and it's going to take a month and it's all
being salt,
salt.
But definitely sugar first get off the sugar because sugar,
you have to match it.
If you drink colas and if you eat lots of bread and pasta does,
that's all tons of sugar in there and your body has to match that.
It wants more sugar.
So if you drink a bunch of coke than it wants to sugar foods.
So when this woman walks in,
if you were in the house and you got a yellow light,
oh my gosh,
I gotta be in the back.
I got to shut up,
get off.
I will get in her face and be like,
get off the sugar.
Wipe it out of your,
during your hat around backwards.
Put the whistle in my mom.
Listen.
Kicked dirt over a cake.
It's hilarious.
The fuck are you looking at out there?
That's fucking great.
All Day.
What?
This shit is hilarious.
Nah Man,
that's the thing.
You came in here but one reason and why was that?
Do I need all of our tanks?
That's in Earl weaver reference.
You came in here to fuck us up cause good and you got your chance of getting the
mark.
No,
I dead.
Naral no,
I dare yet dead.
You'll get your chance again tomorrow.
I love when he says that.
That,
that I'm fine.
It was so great.
Like what are you going to do or I'll lose another world.
Sarah.
I want more than I lost.
Not World Series Games.
Eagles Games.
Yeah.
All right,
where are we going?
Video,
uh,
Bill this,
this video isn't mine,
but I came across on Youtube.
I actually watched some,
it's the evolution of Walter White.
Um,
somebody did like this great like 15 minute video where they go from the very
first episode and it just take like the key scenes.
I watched like a minute and a half of it before,
but I was just getting chills and my guy,
right.
I got one of the reasons why it's one of the great shows of all time.
Um,
all right,
two girls dare bill.
I'm just some kid in high school,
doesn't know Jack all about dating.
But a week ago I learned that a chick I knew but didn't like head put me on her
phone as a wallpaper.
This apparently has been going on for a year and I just learned about a,
from one of her friends.
I knew this chick like me,
but I couldn't stand her.
Oh,
this is weird.
You said a,
I tried letting her down.
I tried being a dick to her just to,
uh,
why can't you just be honest?
Did you know what?
Cause you're young and just be like,
listen,
I know you really liked me,
but I'm not feeling that way about you.
You say,
which is a bitch.
Okay.
Um,
she just acting like I am still all hers.
Yeah,
that would get annoying.
I knew she was into me while I was still a freshman,
but it was near summer,
so I thought she would just forget all about it.
Um,
and if that wasn't enough,
her friends that told me this,
uh,
tried hitting on me when she told him what is,
if this wasn't enough.
Her friend told me
this tea tried hitting on me.
Dude,
you guys got to proof read the shit.
You gotta let me tell you something.
If you're in high school,
you're not going to make it to college.
All right,
hang on.
Just keep talking.
Like as I tried to dissect this,
whatever he wants,
he butchered it.
Is this a guy that's talking about a girl with his phone?
It'd be glad.
Listen,
do listen be,
oh,
I got it.
Yeah.
There's no common as if this wasn't enough.
Her friend that told me this tried hitting on me when she told me.
Oh,
okay.
Yeah.
See there was no punctuation in there.
Um,
okay,
so now the girl that tells you that this girl is obsessed with you then hits on
you.
Okay.
First of all,
I just learned some psycho had me on a wallpaper for a year and I didn't know.
So the last thing I wanted to think about is dating second.
What a bitch move on a friend's part.
Hitting on a guy.
This guy is definitely the glass is half full.
Huh?
What the fuck?
You got two women here.
I know dude.
And it's have added and it's like you're hitting on a guy.
Her friend has been stocking bill.
I'm ready to tell them the both go,
go fuck themselves.
But what is your opinion on this?
Uh,
you ignore the first girl,
you bang the second one and then you get on with your life.
What do you think Jay?
I think you a,
I think you,
you,
you play them into each other.
I mean,
I think that if these girls are friends together,
any other girls hitting on you?
Right.
Thank you.
I think you,
I think you will,
you're going for the three way.
Oh yeah,
man.
I'm going for,
I'm going for the threeway early.
I'm,
I'm going to the hole,
get,
get together.
Let's do this as like a group and hang out.
You know,
an onside kick play,
a little dumb on starts to gain a little dumb on the whole,
I don't know really everything about the phone and I'm not the girl with the
phone.
I'm not going to give up the fact that I,
this other one was kind of hitting on me.
I'm going to let this all come together and see where it goes and that had,
or if he's eating grass.
Yeah,
because you know why they're there.
The ones that you're,
they're bringing it to you,
they're serving it to you on a platter.
I mean,
they're literally,
you are,
you're the,
you're the reason why this whole thing is developing.
So let it,
let these two Kinda,
Ya know,
just sit back.
Relax.
All right,
so email la heads court.
He'll tell you how to tell you how to bring them in.
It's going to be instrument landing here up my sleeves.
Um,
all right.
Fat Shaming,
golf,
Dota.
Uh,
Billy Burrito.
What a good way to fat.
Shame.
Uh,
what's a good way to fat.
Shame.
A sense.
Why am I becoming the fat shame personnel,
right?
You're like,
fuck yeah.
I don't want to make people feel bad about being fat.
I mean,
I'm joking around about this shit.
I want people to be in shape so I don't fucking hang this thing around me.
Uh,
I'm not going to read.
That's two in one week.
That'll be bad.
The next thing you know,
I got some group.
Yeah.
You know,
I know it's jokes,
but it sets a precedent.
Is a bunch
of people protesting in front of you?
They're not gonna.
They're not gonna because like,
that's another good reason not to have
fucking goofy.
She's got people in scooters driving around.
No.
But if he,
if he had a fucking TV show then they actually get it.
This shit about,
cause they get,
they can't fire you from stand up
or my podcasts,
they can they a take away the advertiser.
But I'd still do it.
I don't give a fuck,
uh,
advice on friends.
Hey Bill.
I'm a,
I'm in a junior,
a junior in high school and I've got one group of really good friends,
like eight or nine people.
We are like the funny guys of our school always giving each other shit.
Well there's one friend and he was an asshole for an entire summer to my other
friends who was a girl that he liked a lot.
There you go.
That's,
that's American public schools right there.
There's one,
well there's one for j.
Talk again,
tell these people,
it's unbelievable.
It's just a friend,
you know,
get read a book.
I mean all these auto corrects and grammar checks on compute.
I mean,
how do you not get out in front of right email that you want with every bit of
technology that we have?
I just,
I'm stunned.
Okay.
I got it.
I figured it out.
Thank you.
Okay,
so there's,
well his one friend and he was an asshole for an entire summer to my other
friend who was a girl that he liked a lot.
So this guy is friends with this girl and this other guy liked her lawn.
He's been an asshole tour.
Um,
okay.
He started treating her like shit when she told him she didn't like him and
well,
things were heated all summer and it was weird.
Uh,
I was letting the girl know that he was saying what I was letting the girl know
what he was saying and due to her and now they are.
But at Jake talk again,
just,
just talk to the people here.
Well I don't even know what he started out by saying we got,
I got nine buddies that are like the funny guys that are group.
I was more interested in that.
Like I thought he was gonna go somewhere with like,
hey,
we're doing the like I don't,
I don't even know.
I mean,
he's just now,
he's just like,
he's guy basically whittled it down to three p buddy was saying was this kid
went over,
he ratted out the girl.
He's saying this and that to the other thing he said,
now this asshole guy and this girl who's a friend are like buddy buddy again,
because the other guy said that the dude writing this letter was lying and none
of it was true,
which of course she's gonna believe the other guy because she likes him.
This guy's going to real or right in.
Oh no,
she doesn't.
He likes her.
Wow.
That's weird.
So why the fuck was she believed that he basically got everyone against me and I
don't know what to do.
This guy's a psycho manipulating everyone.
He acts like he doesn't say anything and he acts overtly nice to me when he's
around me.
Yeah,
this guy's a psycho and it pisses me off.
He won't tell the truth to anyone.
So my question is,
should I even try to fight back against this and try to win back my few close
friends or should I just tell them to go fuck themselves and try to make new
friends?
So you got ostracized by everybody?
Um,
look who gives a fuck at this point?
If she doesn't believe you,
then fuck her.
Let this guy do whatever the hell he wants to do with her.
Um,
it's got to come back,
listen,
walk away,
beat a bigger and take the high road.
Walk away like that.
Like that gun fighter in the West walking away by himself and this guy,
the other guy will end up doing this to other people and he'll do it to her.
And I'd be like,
dude,
you know,
whatever this guy's name is Johnny is man.
He's the,
he's the real deal.
And you don't what?
You don't need people like that in your life.
Do that early.
Get used to that early,
getting those kinds of people.
No,
it is.
I'm telling you,
learn,
learn how to cut the weeds early,
man.
I tell you what,
because as you get older,
you don't want to get into those habits,
man.
It's just like a,
it's like,
you know,
what does it like abused women,
man,
they get into a habit and I'm not comparing it to that a little bit there,
but you know,
you don't want to get into that habit of being walked on and,
and treat it that way.
And just including yourself in a group of friends because you're like,
oh,
I don't know what else to do.
How will I get new friends?
That's that dude.
No,
no.
And you got to cut the weeds.
You do,
Dude.
I did.
I took me to 40 to realize that.
And I,
in the last just learning last five,
six years,
I cut out all the negative people in my life and the level of drama that just,
it was like a vacuum.
It just got sucked right out of the room.
And,
um,
recently I was around,
I was just doing some Gig and I end up just getting in like this social circle
of just three or four people that were used to be like the kinds of people I
used to fucking hang out with.
And uh,
I immediately sensed like negative energy,
which I had never felt before because I was so used to it.
Right.
I was like,
I,
I was one of those guys my whole fucking life,
just like,
you know,
when I fucking get out of this house,
I'm going to do it,
blah blah.
And then you go out in the world because that's all,
you know,
you just recreate that whole fucking thing over again.
It's totally what I did and took me like 20 years to cut all of that shit out.
And uh,
there's also that,
that,
you know,
I'm very forgiving of psychos.
I am a psycho,
but I'm quite temperamental maniac for so many years in my twenties and early
thirties,
you know,
and it's like to be self sufficient and just become a complete fucking loner.
Yeah,
that's what you did is you go out like that.
Fucking the hearse guy.
They're looking at a house he had.
Yeah,
exactly.
But that's what the true though.
You got like a gunfighter man and you just walk like,
you know,
shame man.
You just go,
go out and ride out.
Ride out on these people.
It's fucking Hilarious,
right?
I got to read a couple of,
uh,
I got to read a couple more advertising things and I want to hear your opinions
on the first two weeks.
Two and a half weeks,
because we're still in the middle of football Sunday here.
Oh,
by the way,
we got,
we had talked about your,
you thought you fucking big day for Imam jacked up,
man.
I think we might have a football team on our hands.
Finally.
All right.
Dollar Shave Club.
Everybody.
Uh,
ever wonder why raises are so expensive.
Big shape companies are charging you for ridiculous shave technologies that you
don't even know.
Don't even need first vibrating vibrating handles.
Then flashlights.
Now pivot ball,
flex heads.
It's all crap.
What are they going to put an MP three player.
They write jokes for me here.
Enough is enough.
Join the dollar shave club.com revolution for just a few bucks a month.
Dollar Shave club.com delivers the world's best razors right to your door.
Now I'm dollar shave club dot coms blades are better than the big shave
companies for a fraction of the price.
It's so easy.
Go to dollar shave club.com pick one of their razors.
They just start for three bucks a month.
You don't have to break the bank.
You don't have to resort to cheap disposable razors to shit to save cash.
Dollar Shave club.com is amazing.
Every month they ship you automatic deliveries.
You'll never have to go to the Goddamn pharmacy again or drugstore or whatever
the hell you call it and stand in line behind the old people trying to get ice
cream and get their photos developed.
All right?
You can just have the shit delivered right to your house.
You don't have to squeeze shaves in it on a dry,
dull,
dirty old razor.
You get to shave with a fresh blade every week.
This is absolutely mandatory for anybody that wants to get a great shave.
You deserve better than a dull blade for the love of God.
Treat yourself no more ridiculous.
Shave technology.
Make a smarter choice like millions of people have joined.
Dollar Shave club.com/bird.
That's dollar shave club.com/burr.
All right.
Um,
ie voice everyone.
I love the flexibility that owning your own business provides.
Well,
that would help if I owned a business.
Why do they do this to me?
I know a voice knows what they're doing.
Listen,
you'll love the flexibility of owning your own business.
Who wouldn't?
Who wants to work for some day?
Look at me.
I've created an empire with this show.
I see them breaking my balls here,
but when it comes to handling business calls,
you're,
you're stuck with the challenge.
Either hire a full time recipient or handle all of your calls yourself.
It's a lose,
lose situation.
Uh,
that's why he voices the shit.
All right?
They will set up your business with a toll free number or local number.
When a customer calls,
they are greeted by a professionally,
professionally,
by a virtual receptionist that will route all of your calls to wherever you are.
That's even a dial.
There's even a dial by name directory.
Um,
you'll sound like a fortune 500 company.
And more importantly,
you'll never miss an important call.
All of this for how much?
13 bucks a month.
Right now for a limited time,
my listeners can try he voice for free for 60 days.
Seriously,
my listeners get an extended 60 day trial to test drive this amazing business
tool.
That's right.
60 days.
Just for our listeners,
go to [inaudible] dot com slash bill now to sign up,
set up your eve voice,
um,
60 day free trial right now at [inaudible] dot com slash bill that's a
voice.com/bill and mercifully,
I have one more read.
I said,
I'm sorry guys.
This is even worse than usual.
All right,
I'm reading for prosper.
Everyone Prosper in 72 hours.
You could have $35,000 to cover your needs.
What will you do?
Pay Off high credit card rates.
Start a business,
do that.
Home Improvement Projects,
that's what I'm going to do.
Throw it into the downstairs.
Um,
why with our sponsor prosper,
it's with our sponsor prosper.
It's never been easier.
Go Online,
answer a few questions and see your low fixed rate in seconds.
Your money hits your account in as little as three days.
Um,
prospers the fastest growing peer to peer lender group and they're facilitated
over $1 million.
They facilitated over $1 million of loans to people like you.
They should know better than it.
Use that word and copy that.
I'm going to read.
Their Revolutionary Platform connects people looking to borrow money with those
who have money to invest.
There's no outrageous fees,
no raising,
raising,
raising interest rates,
and you'll never have to set foot in a bank.
Just go to prosper.com/burr to check your rate instantly without affecting your
credit score.
For a limited time.
Prosper is offering my listeners a $50 visa prepaid card.
When you get alone.
Go to prosper.com/burr up to for $35,000 in just three days and a $50 gift card.
Go to prosperity slash [inaudible] dot com slash burr mandatory.
Disclaimer,
other restrictions apply.
See the site for details.
Gift Card is issued by Centerstate Bank of Florida pursuant to license from Visa
usa.com all personal loans are made by Web Bank,
a Utah chartered industrial bank member,
FDIC equal housing lender.
Wow.
To answer that one guy's first question on the Fan Mail doing Christ,
to answer that one guy's first question on a fan mail,
but why don't you do TV?
We know why he doesn't do commercials.
Yeah.
Isn't that the fucking truth that's read there?
Yeah,
that's,
that's some heavy duty.
Uh,
I like that.
That is outside the dollar shave club though.
That's a good idea.
Even though I have a beard and I grew that because I literally grew my beard for
years ago because of the prices of razors.
I mean,
I'm like,
you know,
you,
you got to go date.
There's two things that they lock up in the store.
Did you know that?
Liquor and razors,
I mean you got to go get a guy with a key.
Yeah.
That's how it's always been.
There always been a complete rip off.
I've never understood it.
And you know,
it's funny drilling through these things with the offshore drill for rate,
I mean the appraiser razors for what you get is,
is what I grew this beard.
It was because,
okay man,
I'm not.
Do you remember?
Do you remember the late night they actually had that sharpener that you could
stick your rating?
That thing came and went in two seconds.
I bet the big race companies,
even the it bombed or they just bought it out.
Yup.
They bought it out.
The or the Oh,
the creator of it was in a diner.
It was just like all of a sudden they poisoned me and fucking ran out and died
in the parking.
Well,
they probably just bought the patent to it and then just,
you know,
kept it under a lot of people by patents and then just hide them from everybody
so
they can't compete with them.
I Dunno.
Wait,
let's talk browns before we get the fuck out of it.
We'll get back up.
Oh Jesus.
That dog pound Horse Shit.
Sorry.
No grown man.
I never liked it from the start.
We have a,
we actually have a dog now.
The first time we have a dog.
That's cool.
Like a real dog.
We named.
Oh yeah,
we've got a bolt,
Matt Brown,
Bull mastiff named swagger is his first year as the like.
So he kinda sits on the sidelines and just kind of licks himself.
I said,
Jesus,
this guy,
I said when I first got them on the guy,
just this dog,
you know,
I don't know if this is a good timing with the way are these this things gonna
this thing's going to run out in front of a car after the week three,
probably just fucking throw himself in traffic on the,
on the,
uh,
what happened?
I was in one man.
So,
uh,
you know,
we tried to give it away to New Orleans.
We had a great first half and then,
uh,
we just,
when you came in and start doing a POC as we made,
we went like,
I just heard you yell.
Yeah.
87 yard.
Well we didn't go all 87 yards,
but we started I think on the 13 with about two and a half minutes ago and Hoyer
took us down the field and we had,
uh,
you know,
we would,
we had a great catch on the side.
Miles Austin at a great catch on the sidelines at about the 39 to keep the big
drive going.
And then we,
uh,
a big defensive breakdown.
We hit it,
we hit a receiver down the middle to the 10 with four seconds ago and kind of
hit the game winning field goal 26,
24 browns over the saints who a lot of people think the saints are going to be
in that fucking vinyl for mixed one and one.
And we shouldn't be Pittsburgh.
We lost a Pittsburgh.
You don't have a horrific defense or something.
Well,
it looked bad last week against Atlanta and it,
it didn't look great against us today.
Well,
Rex Ryan,
or not rex Ryan,
the fat one and the one that needs the one,
it needs to get off the sugar.
The Ryan,
he fad.
I Dunno.
The ugly,
right?
The hair,
they look the same.
They'll take no,
well,
rex went on that lap band.
What's the guy's name?
Rob.
Rob has one of those light,
just disgusting stomachs.
You know what I mean?
Like he's got like the skinny legs,
the regular like neck and arms and then he's just got one of those man pregnant
bellies.
It's disgusting.
Well,
you're one on one.
I want to hear what I want.
Can I hear something positive from a Cleveland Browns?
I like it.
I think we got a good coach on our hands.
I said even after the first loss and,
and watching a little bit is I twitch tweeted out,
I go,
I think,
you know,
I think we actually have a well coached football team on our hands,
which we just haven't had.
We just,
I mean,
we,
we just haven't had a coach right,
since we've come back as the Brown.
We haven't had a coach since Bella check and now those are the guys that are
right.
And the last time we won a playoff game as the Cleveland Browns who are now the
Baltimore Ravens but has the Brown,
you beat us.
We beat,
we beat the bill Parcells patriots in a wild card game at Cleveland and Bill
Bellacheck is right.
Right.
All
coach became the master 20 years ago.
That's 20 seasons ago.
Alright,
well I'm a,
I'm a closet Cleveland browns fan,
so I hope you guys have a great season.
Uh,
I'm psyched.
The Patriots won and we were like,
I got nervous after that first drive.
Um,
but you know,
Adrian Peterson wasn't there,
so,
uh,
but I know we did do some things,
but I don't know when I,
when I saw Seattle on that first game and I then watched the 40 niners,
I'm just like,
it's just so clear that the NFC,
you know,
if everybody stays healthy that the Superbowl is because I got that way again.
It hadn't stopped playing from last year.
I said,
we have to have week one.
I'm,
they look like they're eight weeks.
Do peak hours.
I mean,
I've never been more wrong about that guy.
I was like,
that guy.
And he's,
he just has that Nice guy look upon him.
When he coached the Patriots,
I was just like,
this guy doesn't have it.
And then even when he did well at,
at,
uh,
USC,
I was just like,
well,
you know,
he's not,
he's not a fucking NFL coach.
Someone who never coached football.
I'm sitting there saying,
this guy is not an NFL coach.
And he won like two or three championships.
Well,
the crazy thing is,
is now the NFL,
that was always the hit.
You couldn't be a college because the college coach,
other than Jimmy Johnson,
the college boy college coach never came in and did it any,
anything in the NFL.
And none of them.
Nick Saban,
Lou Holtz,
none of them very swept.
That was Jimmy's team.
That was,
come on,
that's sad.
But none of them could do that.
But the trend has changed because football has changed.
The quarterback in football has changed to a college style quarterbacks.
So now you got Pete Carroll ultimately successful,
Jim Harbaugh arch,
really successful.
You got chip Kelly now the eagles turning that thing around real quick.
So you're going to see more turning around the culture in the law.
College coaches are successful now in the NFL and it,
you know,
what more do they give Johnny Manziel a chance.
No,
nicely horror.
He screwed the pooch on the side of the fucking field there.
Yeah.
You know,
listen to Brian Hall or Brian Hoyer.
It looks great and to,
he knows the playbook and the team is playing for him.
And you tried to suggest that Johnny was not learning the playbook.
He isn't.
Where did you hear that?
We heard that in some articles that came out of training camp.
Why he was shooting himself in the foot because they were giving him chances to
win this job even though Hoyer,
she was the number one guy.
Putin was a new coach and he was giving him a chance to win a job.
And some of the,
some of the articles coming out of cleveland.com it was saying that he was not
grasping the playbook.
I think that means he's not learning the playbook or you know,
he's a,
I'll tell you this kid has had every opportunity in the world,
but if you're not going to sit down and learn your x's and o's,
I mean the team's not going to get behind you.
And if that doesn't happen,
it is very difficult to win in this league.
These guys.
Okay.
They will hurt you.
They weren't,
they are terrific in punk coverage and they are excellent creativity on fourth
and well as a Huey Brown with doing football.
There's not one woman left.
It listens to this podcast.
This is just a sausage fest.
I got,
fuck it.
I can have a fight.
I don't think I've ever had a female guest.
How by I don't think I ever heard your wife.
No,
no.
I mean like a,
like a fucking outside of somebody I live with.
Um,
have I had a female comic con here?
I guess I haven't.
Oh,
okay.
Am I sexist?
All right.
This is it everybody.
This is the end of the podcast.
Thank you so much for listening.
Uh,
congratulations to everybody's team one this week.
you know,
it's only week two.
Don't get too down on your team.
If they lost,
that's it.
Go fuck yourselves and I'll talk to you next week.